society you think of wealth as the
measuring stick of our lives and you
think of money as the measuring stick
and the reason is actually a functional
one in my opinion which is just that
it's the easiest it's so easy to like
stack yourself on the scoreboard of
money i met way too many people that had
astronomical amounts of money that i
would not qualify as happy by any
stretch of the imagination you know i
have a close friend who sold his company
for a billion dollars recently he made
300 million dollars i was asking him
like are you materially happier now than
you were when you were just running the
company and he said not really and the
reason is because
hey friends welcome back to deep dive
the weekly podcast where i chat to
creators entrepreneurs authors and other
inspiring people and we talk about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies techniques ideas mental
models that we can apply to our own
lives to help us live our best lives now
what you're about to hear is a fantastic
conversation if i say so myself between
me and sahil bloom sahil is an ex-pro
athlete he used to be a professional
baseball player and now he is an
entrepreneur he's an angel investor and
he's absolutely huge on twitter he's
like one of my favorite accounts to
follow on twitter he's grown from zero
to like 500 000 plus followers in like
less than a year and the stuff he tweets
is just freaking amazing personal
development life advice mental models
type stuff sai has also recently become
a dad and so we talk about how that's
affected his approach to like life and
happiness and productivity and i've
learned so much from this conversation i
hope you enjoy it as much as i did sahil
welcome to the show thank you so much
for joining us thank you for having me
this is gonna be so much fun i've been
following you on twitter i feel like
you've absolutely exploded on the
twitter scene in the last like year or
so so we definitely want to talk about
that but i'd love to get started by kind
of talking about what it's been like as
a new dad i'm curious because you have
had a pretty illustrious career and then
you had a kid and i've heard from some
people that when you're like a tech bro
and then you have a kid suddenly it
gives you this new found motivation for
life because now you have a reason to
ascend the ladder and acquire more
because it comes at it comes at this for
the sake of your kid rather than just
for the sake of yourself how has your
leg of drive and motivation changed
since becoming a father yeah there's so
much to unpack here i think it's a great
place to start the conversation because
it actually speaks a lot to you know to
me and to my changing motivations and
how i feel as a human being i you know
first off what i would say is i think
there is this general weird almost
cynicism around parenthood that has
permeated through culture broadly where
like you know you say you're having a
kid and everyone's first reaction is
like oh you know get your sleep now or
uh you know like i hope you had fun you
know i hope you had your fun years in or
you know like all of the all the stuff
is like you know people are sort of
saying it jokingly but there is this
feeling of like your life is kind of
over like that part of your life is over
and the fun days and the sleeping and
you know being clean and all all of
those things are done and i just
generally like
as a bias whenever there is a broad
sweeping feeling or push in one
direction i try to push back against or
at least see the other side and so going
in i was like i had boundless optimism
around it i was not going to be cynical
about the experience i was like
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me my wife and i you know
candidly had you know tried for a little
while and we weren't sure we were going
to be able to conceive naturally and it
was a real blessing that it ended up
happening for us and so i was just so
taken by the fact that we were going to
have a son that this was all going to
happen that i couldn't see anything with
the positive in all of it and the second
he was born you know i had this like
really profound feeling where i got to
hold him and i had this feeling of like
look i'm 31 years old and i've spent the
last 31 years of my life or maybe that's
not realistic the last 26 years of my
life trying to understand what the
meaning and purpose is of all of this
like of life what are we doing why am i
working what am i doing all these things
for and then suddenly i was standing
there and that was looking me straight
back in the face like that meaning and
purpose and i really did feel that way i
was like oh this is why i'm here like
this is the whole reason and ever since
then it's just been this like
transformative day after day for me as a
as a human being and you know i don't
even mean that in like a
grandiose sense i really mean it very
literally on a daily basis i for the
first time in my life feel like i really
have enough and so you said you know at
the beginning people feel like it's this
motivation now i have a why i'm gonna go
out and i'm gonna you know go accelerate
my career i'm gonna go make more money
i'm gonna do it for him you know for
this kid and i've actually gone the
other way where i'm like i want to spend
time
with this child i don't want to be
working 100 hours a week to try to like
make more money and have a yacht and a
private jet and this and that i want to
get to be a huge part of his life i want
to coach his little league team like i
want to be able to spend time with him
when he's doing all these things and so
it's it's interesting i think people go
one of two ways with it and i've
definitely gone the direction of just i
want to be around i really want to enjoy
this and be able to support him nice i
love that that's great can we zoom in so
you said that you were you were looking
at this baby thinking yep this is
meaning and purpose this is why i'm here
can we unpack a little bit is it like
i'm here to help this baby survive i'm
here to help this baby thrive like what
what is what's going on in your head
when you have that kind of feeling yeah
i mean i am a thinker by by nature like
i i would say i generally overthink
things and a lot of time during my like
career post age like i don't know maybe
really post age 20. i spent a lot of
time just thinking about like my
motivations like why am i doing this why
am i getting up why am i working hard
what am i like what am i trying to do
what's my reason for being and not like
that i was feeling depression or feeling
anxiety or anything i just i wanted to
know what i was striving for and i would
say i like a lot of people i imagine our
age fell into this pattern and cycle of
like
hey you know i'm doing this because
everyone says this is what i'm supposed
to do like i'm supposed to try to you
know climb the ladder in this finance
job to make a bunch of money so that i
can have 30 million dollars someday or
whatever the number is and so then i can
you know have fancy wine at dinner and i
never really stopped to think like is
that really what i want does that make
me happy intrinsically and if happiness
is what i ultimately am striving for as
a human being why why am i then doing
this and when i had you know when i had
that first interaction when i looked him
in the eye i just felt that sensation
right there of like
this is actually happiness this is my
true moment and like the purity of that
feeling and of that happiness was
unrivaled in my life and so what i
realized in that moment was um it wasn't
you know taking care of this child you
know being there
etc it was literally that feeling of
like this is what pure joy feels like
this is what enough feels like i don't
need a yacht or a plane or fancy wine or
fancy food or restaurants or a nice
house etc it's like this connection that
i feel is all i ever really want okay so
i'm 28 and i feel as you were describing
all the stuff around like uh why am i
here why am i striving that's literally
what i've been playing in my mind for
the last like 12 months or so struggling
to come up with an answer
because i think one of the nice things
about the medical career path is that
you don't really have to ask yourself
that question because it's like you sort
of are on following the yellow brick
road and there's always a next step and
there's always a next step and
it's a very clear path but then as soon
as i stepped off that path especially as
like the youtube channel and the
business started making more money
especially when i got to the point where
i'm like damn you know i've i was
intending to build streams of passive
income i have streams of passive income
what's the point now is it to build more
more and more streams of passive income
like more financial independence but
like to what end i i kind of just want
to spend my time reading writing and
teaching and that seems kind of fun but
like i don't need that much money for
that but like i still feel like i still
still need to make all this money
and i've been really struggling to
figure out like why am i actually
striving for all this kind of stuff so
i'm curious if you like pre-kid what
were your conclusions um because we
talked a little bit about what happened
post kid that like suddenly it's all
about this but like what how were you
thinking about this kind of before
before you had the camera yeah i think
this answer actually applies to pre and
post kid you know notwithstanding all of
that of like feeling like i have enough
both pre and post kid i had had this
realization um that
i was on
you know i was in the finance world
right so it's pretty similar actually to
the medical world where there was this
nice neatly trodden path from point a
where i was standing to point b when i
was age 65 and life had gone great and i
was retiring and i was wealthy and
had accomplished everything that you're
supposed to accomplish as like a you
know you know the son of an indian
immigrant like that would have been a
good life my mom would have been proud
he's like oh he made money took care of
us etc that scared the [ __ ] out of me
excuse my language um that i could like
put my head down blink and wake up in 25
years and be like what the hell just
happened what did i just do and did i
enjoy it no was i like nerding out on a
daily basis excited about what i was
doing no and what was it gonna steal my
happiness and my joy along the way
probably when i started to deconstruct
it you know again it goes back to me
being an overthinker i started to
deconstruct it a bit i just generally
realized that society i think of wealth
as the measuring stick of our lives and
you think of money as the measuring
stick and the reason is actually a
functional one in my opinion which is
just that it's the easiest it's so easy
to like stack yourself on the scoreboard
of money and i met way too many people
that had astronomical amounts of money
that i would not qualify as happy by any
stretch of the imagination because what
happened and you know i have a close
friend who sold his company for a
billion dollars recently he made 300
million dollars and i was asking him
like are you materially happier now than
you were when you were just running the
company and he said not really and the
reason is because you know he was like
look i sold the company it was great i
got invited to all these like cool trips
and i went on this trip and i was there
and i had you know rented this like
really nice yacht for all my friends
when we were there and i got there and
there was just three like bigger yachts
right next to me and so suddenly like
i'm on the thing all my friends are here
come and they all think i'm the man and
then they see these other boats and
everyone's like i wonder who owns that i
wonder what that you know what the story
is with that one because there's always
someone that's gonna have more it's just
the reality of it and so you suddenly
get into this pattern where like it's
never enough everyone has this tendency
where
you know like you mentioned it you know
when you when you're uh when you're a
medical student or when you're trying to
make it in the early years of that
you're trying to basically first like
pay off your debt then you're trying to
maybe make a few million dollars and
then you want 10 million dollars and
then you'll say like oh i'll be happy
when i have 10 million dollars then you
have 10 million and you say you'll be
happy when you have 30 million dollars
the number just triples no matter what
and it's just the reality of how humans
are we get on this hedonic treadmill and
we're never happy and so for me what i
realized was i didn't want that money
actually didn't make me all that happy
what made me happy was freedom
i loved being able to spend time with
people i cared about i loved having the
freedom to work out and to you know feel
physically fit and you know experience
vitality to have headspace mentally to
be able to think about my own mental
health mindfulness spirituality etc and
really experience a much more
comprehensive view of wealth in my own
life and so i started prioritizing that
i started trying to think about okay
what was like my playbook going to be
for building comprehensive wealth and
you know all of that comes out to
happiness right like all of it then
boils down to hopefully a level of
fulfillment and happiness in your own
life how do you think about the
difference between happiness and
fulfillment or happiness and meaning or
like short-term versus long-term
happiness like weather versus climate
like what's your mental model for this
yeah i would say my general model is
that happiness is short-term um and
fulfillment is like the long-term and i
i personally think that like a lot of
happy moments uh will generally lead to
a lot of long-term fulfillment but i
don't think you can generally experience
happiness
in a long-term state i think it's it's
effectively felt in like three second
increments is i think the science of
this like a moment in time is three
seconds from a scientific perspective
and when you feel happiness i personally
think you need to register it like i am
very very good about when i feel happy
i'm like oh hey i feel happy right now
and i want to like mentally register it
so that in my mind i know
hey i felt really happy on several
occasions today this was great because i
think it's easy to just like ignore it
pass it by kurt vonnegut the famous
author has this amazing commencement
speech i think it was like 1997 at rice
he gave a commencement speech and he
said when life is sweet when you have
those like sweet moments in life pause
and look up at the sky and say if this
isn't nice then what is
and i always loved that because it's
this like forced
stop in your life when those moments are
good and we it's so easy when you're a
striver and when you're you know it like
you or like me you're like focused on
growth because you love building you
love growing that's what motivates you
you want to get better each day you say
you love reading and writing and
teaching like why a lot of that comes
down to you love learning like you love
being a little bit better knowing a
little bit more about the world around
you that's happy for you that's
fulfillment for you but we often when
you're like that don't stop you don't
pause you don't appreciate those sweet
sweet moments in life and so i love
being able to pause recognize those
little moments in time and i've just
found it's made a dramatic impact on my
daily happiness and my long-term
fulfillment yeah anytime i come across
that quote i find that like i then do it
for the rest of the day and then i
forget about it and as you were saying
that i was just thinking that like huh
if this isn't nice i don't know what it
is you know having this conversation
followed you on the internet for a while
i get to do this as my job we're in the
middle of a heat wave but it's air
conditioned and it's super nice this is
so good it's completely absurd i mean
when you actually break down i mean your
life i feel the same way about mine
you get to do this for a lit you're
getting paid to have interesting
conversations with smart people not not
me but with other smart people um and
that is amazing that's amazing
considering where you were two years ago
in your life completely remarkable i
think about it every day you know i'm
like i'm at home right now right this is
my office my kid is in the other room
he's two months old if i was in my prior
job i would be traveling three four days
a week i'd be working 90 100 hours a
week and i'm making much less money than
i'm making now and so i have the freedom
and the income to be able to like spend
time with the people that i really love
and care most about with my parents with
my kid with my wife um and if that's not
nice i really don't know what is
fantastic yeah i'm just imagining like
what my life would be like if i were
still working as a doctor probably be in
some like really really really hot
office
dealing with patients coming in through
heatstroke and it would be fun in a way
and it would be feel like camaraderie
but certainly not as great as as as what
this setup is yeah and not as impactful
right i mean like
a doctor's role is amazingly impactful
on the micro level i mean i think that
motivates tons of people and my whole
mental model for life is
you should find the thing
that you are most uniquely well suited
to create the maximum impact around and
you could have created significant
impact as a doctor but i think you're
fantastic you're like you would have
been a great doctor i'm sure no doubt
right like i think you're smart you're
curious you would have been a great
doctor and you would have impacted a lot
of lives but you're fantastic at what
you do now like you're in the top
1.01 percent of the world at being able
to do what you do now and so the number
of people you can impact positively
through doing what you're doing now is
probably a thousand x you know what you
could have as a doctor and so from a
like societal net benefit perspective
matching you into what you should be
doing is a huge positive because so many
people are better off for having you do
that i never would have encountered you
if you were a doctor right you never
would have had a positive net impact on
my life now you are yeah that's
something i do i do think about a lot in
the sense of like measuring impact and
effective altruism and all that kind of
stuff what does motivate you i think
motivation wise i'm just going to think
out loud here if it feels like there's
like the selfish motivations and then
there's like the selfless motivations
shall we say that i want to have a nice
life that i like and i want to have
impact on other people and help other
people in some kind of way and ideally
the venn diagram of those things is the
thing that you end up doing
and i feel like i found that in doing
this sort of stuff basically teaching
online and learning from cool people
like you and just like making videos
about that stuff feels really cool and
it feels like some sort of impact as
well but i guess the thing that i
struggle with is like trying to tease
out
in a way what is the true motivation and
i i don't know if there's a good way to
think about it but one way that i i try
and think about it is
okay let's say i didn't want to i didn't
need to worry about making money anymore
let's say i had 100 million in the bank
which is and hopefully at that point i
wouldn't be trying to seek 300 million
what would i be doing with my time and
i think broadly what i'd be doing with
my time is fairly similar to what i'm
currently doing with my time i'd still
be doing the podcast i'd still be doing
videos probably i'd make less courses or
just chuck them on youtube for free
because
i just put it on the internet for free
but beyond that my life would be very
similar to what it currently is but why
do you need 100 million for that yeah no
that's the next question i don't really
need 100 million for that and i think
i'm already at the point where i can
just probably do that forever because i
don't particularly have expensive tastes
and
this works nicely one thing that i do
struggle with like i have a bit a bit of
a question mark about and i'd love to
hear your perspective on this is in the
back of my mind there's this large
amount of fear of like okay i've sort of
locked locked into this position right
now business is going well youtube
channel's going well you know peaks and
troughs like with any kind of social
media type thing and but it's it almost
feels like i guess being an athlete and
i guess you'd have experience of this
where you know you've got a few years in
the limelight to really make hay while
the sun shines and then you're going to
be hung out to dry you're going to
become a has been and all those fears
are just like in my mind of like
is this a sustainable career for the
long term and especially when i have a
family and kids and stuff
then will i will i regret the way that i
spent my time in my youth and will i
regret not going for 10 million or 30
million instead be comfortable with like
less than that any any thoughts on this
so many look i mean i think this is
first off it's like it's a combination
of like imposter syndrome with this like
scarcity bias that i think we all have
when you first make it where you're like
terribly scared of being broke and you
know being being back to like zero and
for whatever reason rich people feel
this a lot and it's the weirdest thing
in the world just psychologically that
it's almost like functionally very
difficult like you have skills there are
things you can do you'll be fine but we
all experience this and have that type
of fear and look i mean i felt that a
lot i went from like a normal finance
track and like very stable etc to doing
something entrepreneurial and you know
on my own and that doesn't have a
pattern that i can match it to or a
precedent that's set around it you know
my general bias on these things is that
you'll figure it out and you have
incredible energy around what you're
doing and when you have incredible
energy and motivation around what you're
doing intrinsically there is a path that
opens up that you cannot ever predict
and trying to predict it is actually
silly like if a year ago you could have
predicted where you are today i would
call bs and i think that apply you know
you're 28 i would guess at like every
point over the last eight years if you
had tried to predict where you were two
three years out in advance you would
have been wrong and i think that applies
to today i actually don't know if you're
still going to be doing this in two or
three years but i do know you're going
to be fine and you're going to be like
figured out something really cool that
you're going to be working on and doing
and you know the last piece like more
tactically that i think about a lot is i
think about income and wealth separately
and so i think that what you really want
an ideal setup from a life perspective
is that you have
income generating activities and then
you have wealth generating activities
and the way i generally think about it
is that you take your income generating
activities you want those to obviously
like cover your expenses etc as soon as
all of that is covered you're taking all
of that income and deploying it into
wealth generating activities and if you
set up a simple set of systems in that
way it's very difficult to like ever be
truly in trouble and if you're
especially during a period where you're
earning at a high level not all of a
sudden having your like you know your
lifestyle creep up to the point where
there's no net excess at the end of the
day from the income generating is the
way to make sure that you're always fine
i mean i've just like personally i've
always had these fears and so i've
personally built like a little personal
model of my life of how i'm thinking
about taking like excess that's being
generated and deploying it into things
that i consider wealth generating
investing you know my fund that i have
all things like that and make sure that
like look if i die or if i can't work
and we have literally zero income how
long can we coast on what we have for
and when you get to like i mean my
general goal is to like get to the point
over the next couple of years where it's
like forever you know like we can we can
make do with our current lifestyle
forever and i think that's an amazing
place of like i call it default alive
it's like paul graham has an essay on
this but getting to the point where you
feel like your default alive from a
personal finance standpoint is a massive
mental unlock alrighty let's do a little
interlude now i want to tell you about
one of my favorite books which is steal
like an artist by austin cleon austin
cleon's books have like profoundly
changed the trajectory of my life sure
your work in particular is the book that
first encouraged me to start my own blog
way back in 2016. but still like an
artist is really good somebody hit the
new york times bestseller list with this
book that's like actually mostly a
collection of illustrations but like
genuinely sick and it's great for you
know creatives and people struggling
with originality and stuff i would
recommend reading the book it's actually
not very long it doesn't take very long
to read but if you want another way of
engaging with the ideas in the book then
you might like to check out short form
who are very kindly sponsoring this
episode if you haven't heard by now
short form is the world's best service
that summarizes popular non-fiction
books but it's way more than just book
summaries so for each book they have a
one pager that summarizes the book in a
single page they also have detailed
chapter by chapter outlines and so for a
book like still like an artist where
there's not a lot of text in the book
the short form summary adds to and
builds on the ideas of austin cleon
himself then in between some of the
chapters they've got these interactive
exercises which help you engage with the
topic a little bit more and if the
author says anything particularly
controversial then short form will often
flag up that hey this is a thing that
might be potentially fake news lol here
is another author and what they thought
about the thing and how they disagreed
with author a and so it's quite nice as
a way of getting a balanced viewpoint
about the books that we read now there's
two main ways that i use short form in
my life the first one is that if i'm
short on time and if i've got a book
recommendation and i'm not 100 sold on
whether i want to read the book directly
i'll often look at the short form
summary of the book and be like you know
are these ideas interesting enough that
i will actually want to read the book
itself and usually i have about a 50 hit
rate with this i tend to read about 50
of the books that i read the summaries
of and don't read 50 of the books that i
read the summaries of which because i
have a never ending to read list this is
actually really helpful and secondly
short form is good as a way of
revisiting ideas from books i've already
read so if i'm doing book research for
my own book or if i'm making a video or
if i'm just trying to revisit the ideas
because i think they'd be particularly
relevant to my life then it's often way
easier for me to read the short form
summary of the book than it is just
reread the whole book anyway if any of
that sums up your street and you would
also like to get access to the world's
best book summaries then head over to
short form dot com forward slash deep
dive and that will give you 20 of the
annual premium subscription so thank you
very much short form for sponsoring this
episode so okay so income income versus
wealth take income generating activities
and use those to cover your expenses and
then transition for transfer basically
everything else into wealth generating
activities you said the phrase set up
simple systems can you zoom in on that
like what sort of simple systems do you
have this sort of thing so i mean the
first one i mentioned is like create a
model of your of your finances i i'm a
huge believer in just being able to like
look at things and visualize them for
peace of mind and like if you're like me
i think most people our age are probably
like this where you have this level of
fear and like scarcity around what your
life is going to look like and if
everything goes to crap you know like
right now say we're in a recession and i
lose my job or you know we're in the
creator economy quote unquote like if
people pull back spend and advertisers
pull back and all this you know people
stop spending money on courses cetera
like will i be okay and i think
visualizing it being able to look at it
and pull on all the different levers is
a great starting point that's one one
general system the other way i do it is
honestly like i sketch things out like i
carry around this this notebook with me
and i will just draw like i'll draw that
system like i'll draw a circle income
generating and i'll write all the
different things that are levers within
it and then i'll show like okay here's
my expenses coming out here's where the
rest is going and i'll draw on all of
the wealth generating activities and
yeah i learned that from like walt
disney had this whole thing of like if
you're having trouble with any concept
just draw it out and even if it's a
crappy looking drawing it really helps
you cement it and understand the idea
and have clarity around it so i will do
that frequently i'll just like sketch
things out when i feel that way but
that's that that'd be probably the two
big ones that i would think about from a
system standpoint
i guess like the last thing i would say
is just sit down and think about what
you're like if you were gonna have three
wealth generating activities and you
were only allowed to have three and like
that can be you know one should
definitely be a brokerage account like
you know just basic investing and the
other two can be of your choosing but
you'd never want to get into a point
where you're like inv you know in 30
different things like there's just no
reason for the complexity everyone
there's been this like general trend
towards almost like status flexing on
all of the different alternative
investment classes that you're invested
in you know you're like oh well i you
know invest in master class i have art i
invest in real estate through you know
fundrise or lex or whatever all of these
platforms are and i invest in this and
you literally have like ten thousand
dollars spread across 15 different asset
classes that is like you're much better
off just putting all of that in s p 500
or like into a broad index fund that
charges you nothing because none of
those are like durably generating above
market returns over the long run i just
i don't really believe it even startups
angel investing i think is more about
learning than it is about generating
returns for the most part so all of
these things i think like complexity is
just a demon
that most people run into along the way
and like keeping your life super simple
i mean i have steadily learned this
lesson the hard way where i like will go
down the rabbit hole on something that i
think is going to be a huge game changer
i'll lose money on it and then be like
man i should just put that into my
brokerage account i would have been much
better off
i know what you mean we've been like
within within this business as well
we've definitely suffered from a
complexity creep of like oh as you grow
bigger suddenly there's more
opportunities do that and that and that
and products are products of course
there of course they're of course their
content here and it's just like actually
focusing on the simple stuff of like
what's the bread and butter and just do
that and do it well and do the
fundamentals well then that's probably
way better than trying to be scattered
brained about it yeah and you have an
idea every day like you're a smart guy
you're ambitious you just have
interesting ideas every day and you
write them down and then people want to
go execute against them and the reality
is that like warren buffett had this
thing of like like a list like a
prioritization list and the basic idea
is like write down 20 things that are
important to you like the 20 priorities
for your life cross 10 of them off the
list you're left with 10 things that
really really matter then cross 7 off
the list and you're left with the three
things that truly truly matter and if
anything comes up that is something
that's not on those three you just say
no and it you know it gives you like a
very easy way to cut through the noise
around things and it sounds crazy and
draconian but it really does work
because what ends up happening is when
you say yes and you take on all those
other things now i'm super busy and my
bandwidth and my headspace is strapped
and so then when the like really juicy
opportunity comes along i i can't take
it because i'm so swamped or i'm just
like i don't even have the head space to
think about that i'm not i'm just gonna
say no because i can't and that's a
terrible thing because now you're
missing the high upside stuff because
you took on the you know random one-off
singles yeah we we had a bit of a
tangent we had a two-hour long session
with a marketing agency earlier today
you know run by some people that we're
friends with and we were just sort of
going through the business and figuring
out like what are the main levers and
thinking like oh for courses do we want
sales team a b testing pages and stuff
and what they were saying is like hang
on let's go back to basics what's your
biggest organic channel answer the
youtube channel everything else is way
way way way smaller than that and
they're like how much effort are you
putting to the youtube channel compared
to the other stuff i was like oh not
very much and they were like yeah we
probably want to just double down on the
youtube channel just like focus on the
basic big thing and don't worry too much
about
all of the other little things that we
could and should be doing and that's the
thing i guess in the creator economy and
i guess people with
normal jobs have this as well where
there's this long list of things that
you know you probably should do i
probably should be on tech talk probably
should be doing instagram reels probably
should be doing linkedin posts garyvee
says linkedin and tick tock are big
these days probably should be doing
twitter threads like you do
and also making chat videos for the main
channel also doing the podcast and this
just ends up being this long list of
options
and actually having the i guess
discipline but also like the i think the
scarcity mindset feeds into this because
in my mind i'm thinking [ __ ] tick-tock
is where everyone's going to beat next
year no one's going to be on youtube i'm
going to start making tick-tock content
um and we just sort of get into this
scattergunned kind of approach for the
sake of trying to build a safety net but
actually it's probably counterproductive
and actually building that safety net
yeah it's i mean it's like a constant
challenge right there's a there's always
going to be some new platform some new
thing you know some new opportunity that
you're missing out on that feeling of
fomo i would say in general the ability
to feel and not take action against fomo
is like a superpower of some of the
highest performers in the world like
that ability to remain focused and
ignore the noise and just say like this
is what i'm gonna do well it's like the
bruce lee line of like i don't fear the
man that has ten thousand kicks i fear
the man that has one kick and has
practiced it ten thousand times i think
that that's like
generally an amazing way to think about
life and look i say all these things all
of them are things i struggle with like
i can quote this stuff till kingdom come
but when some new thing comes up i'm
still gonna be like ah should i be doing
that i don't know it's like causing me a
bunch of tension to even think about it
and you say tik tok you say all these
things i'm like oh man i'm not doing any
of this i'm looking at your youtube
channel right now i'm like man this guy
kills it on youtube i have zero youtube
do i need to be doing this um
so it uh you look i
i don't think there's any way around
this stuff but i do tend to think that
being like a king of one thing versus a
jack of all trades is the right approach
long term yeah i do something like i
have the same thing when i look at your
twitter account i'm like oh man zero to
500k in like a year and you've got the
whole angel investing thing off and you
built a fund maybe i should build a fund
someone told me i should make a rolling
fund but like i don't know anything
about it that feels a lot of work i
angel invested in the in a in a dozen
companies or so and i kind of
semi-regret it because
they message me ask asking for things
and i spend i take years to reply to
whatsapp messages and then i feel bad
that i'm not able to actually offer them
offer them decent value and then
ugh and then i read tim ferriss's blog
post about why he stopped angel
investing and i'm like you know what
maybe i should just like i don't know
stop
even though it's not even that many at
least like compared to you and and other
people yeah i mean the more things you
take on our heads only have so much room
in them to like take things on and to to
actually pursue with any degree of
energy or or ferocity and you're wired
the same way as me where like you're
much better off having two things that
you can pursue with all of your might
and energy than you are with a hundred
that you're kind of like
you know putting around and you just
need to figure out what those couple of
things i mean you know it you're
crushing it you're doing great but i
think for a lot of people to take that
message away it's just like don't try to
be everything to everyone like you're
just not you know and honestly it's the
same of like your audience there are
going to be people that don't like the
things you're putting out they're going
to be you know if you're trying to make
it as a creator they're going to be
people that have negative feedback
they're going to be people that don't
like your stuff that's fine i actually
like you know like i write a lot of
things that are kind of general
self-improvement and growth and decision
making and i get plenty of [ __ ] from
people that are like oh you know this is
just the same self-help thing or
whatever like people want to say and my
whole thing is like don't read it if
it's not for you and you don't get value
from it and it doesn't inspire you or
make you feel better or make you feel a
little smarter don't read it like i'm
not asking you to love everything i put
out there that's totally fine i totally
acknowledge it's not for everyone but if
it helps a few people along the way man
that makes me feel pretty good so that's
i mean just generally how i'm thinking
about it just on so i was going to ask
you a question on that front your
twitter threads always seem to go viral
there was one you did a few months ago
now a few weeks ago being like i've just
had a kid here are 30 lessons or
something i would teach my kid and i was
like i read the whole thing i was like
this is sick and i saw the you know
likes and retweets and stuff and i was
like the sick and i looked at the quote
tweets and there was just some people
being like oh my god this guy's the
worst thing i was like what what the
hell it's just like
it was my kid man and people being like
oh my god this guy needs to go die in a
fire and stuff i was like how
how do you how do you react to that sort
of thing when you're literally like here
are some lessons like teach my kid yeah
and people are telling you to like go
die in a fire this goes i didn't read
the go die in a fire one that's new i
like that one yeah i mean like look that
goes back to the point i made at the
beginning there's this weird cynicism
around parenthood and that was actually
my first experience with it was i posted
this thing that i was like you know i
was like almost tearing up writing that
because i was thinking about and
reflecting on my own life and things my
parents taught me and my grandfather
passed away and i you know i was writing
it was very emotional for me to write i
put it out it did you know like 95 of
the response 99 probably realistically
was extremely positive and a lot of
people found value in it but there's
that you know group five percent one
percent whatever it is that got really
angry that i thought that i could teach
my kids something like they they were
like well all you're going to learn
about is like poop on your face and you
know throw up in the middle of the night
and crying all night and you know what
an idiot that he thinks he can you know
teach his kids to he's in for a hard
lesson whatever all of that stuff and i
was just like man what a weird way to
live life like you're just gonna live
life thinking that you're a passenger
and that everything is just gonna happen
to you and you can't create or change or
be the like driver of your own life i
feel like an empathy towards that i
think i forget whether it was gary v i
think it was gary vee that said this
that when he sees haters and that guy
has a lot of haters when he sees haters
his first reaction is to feel empathy
for the person of you know you're like
if you are the type of person that
writes i hope you go die in a fire on
twitter when someone has put something
out you're probably not a very happy
person and there's probably something in
your life that is causing some level of
tension or sadness or depression or
whatever it is that is leading to you
writing that and so it's actually better
rather than getting angry rather than
being upset to feel empathy for that
person to hope that they can find
happiness and peace in a way that they
clearly aren't at the moment the other
thing i would say is like joe rogan was
just on the lex friedman podcast and
talked about this you know he that guy
has obviously a lot of haters out there
for some good reasons and he says he
just doesn't look at it like entirely
you know and it's like an unspoken rule
with his wife that she doesn't bring it
up to him and he just will not look
won't read any of those things won't
engage my policy in general is the
second one person sends like a bad faith
you know negative response to me i'll
just mute them and i don't block anyone
really because it sort of like gives
them a win that they can be like oh i
got under his skin but if you mute them
then i never have to see the thing you
know never have to see their negativity
again so that tends to be my general
policy but look i mean when you're
growing and doing things and you know
putting yourself in the arena there's
always going to be someone on the
sidelines that wants to throw a rock at
you it's just the reality of it and for
all the good that it's brought to my
life i'm fine kind of taking a few of
those stones to the head along the way
this is one of the one of the commonest
fears that i come across when people
want to start youtube channels or start
putting themselves out there in any kind
of capacity it's this worry of
what will i do about the haters i'm not
sure i can take it kind of thing what
was your approach to this like in the
early days when you didn't have such a
large following and
yeah how how did you go about
sort of getting to this very zen place
where you're like yeah i'll take i'll
take it yeah i mean i say i'm at this
end place
just to
qualify i say i'm at the same place it
still bugs me like you know i
i still will see it the first time
before i'm able to mute someone and
it'll bum me out cause i'm like man i'm
trying to put out positive things like
people that know me i'm a pretty nice
guy like i you know my friends i think
like me and i'm generally pleasant to be
around i'm like very positive um and i
hope that comes across on twitter like i
don't fight people back on twitter when
they say things to me i normally will be
like oh sorry you didn't like it or you
know sometimes i'll message people and
just say like hey this was you know in
good faith i wasn't trying to upset
anyone whatever in the early days on
twitter i was putting out extremely like
positive educational content and so i
would say i didn't really encounter any
haters until i was at about 25 or so
thousand followers at which point i
started getting it from like you know
crypto twitter like anonymous um
accounts where there's no ramifications
to talking crap when you're you know an
anonymous account and you're and you're
hidden there and so honestly what i
would do is i would message people and
what i generally found like someone
would send something really mean and i
would message them and say like hey
sorry that whatever i did upset you
was you know generally trying to write
it in good faith whatever i would send a
nice message and like 99
of the time they would come back and be
like oh i'm sorry i'll delete it like
you know when you actually confront
someone with um or like apologize like
hey that wasn't my intention no one
really likes to like fight face to face
they just assume that you're not gonna
react because you're like a big account
and you're not gonna see it or you're
not gonna read it and that there's no
ramifications to their actions and so
when you actually confront someone
generally most people actually back down
and are fine i would say that was
generally my approach in the early days
and again it's like when you're doing
something when you're in the arena it's
not like
never worry about the opinions of the
people that are on the sidelines that's
just my general bias it's like there's
plenty of people on the sidelines that
are too afraid to put themselves out
there you should take a lot of pride in
being willing to put yourself out there
because it's scary it's vulnerable it's
lonely and when you do that you should
stop taking advice from people that are
on the sidelines how do you what while
we're on the topic how do you balance in
in terms of the stuff that you put out
there the sense of i want to share this
versus i think this will perform well
very difficult the platforms and the
algorithms
and your emotions always lead you
towards wanting to do the thing that
performs well i've talked to many
youtubers that feel this way that it's
like i basically repurpose my top videos
over and over again in new formats
because i know they'll do really well
and that the algorithm will do it and
i'm so addicted to the like you know
dopamine of this many views or whatever
it is that i just keep doing it over and
over and not just the dopamine at that
point the economics of it twitter's a
little different there's no embedded
monetization this isn't twitter my like
writing on twitter is not how i make
money um indirectly sure it you know
leads to all of the other business
things i do but not directly i try to
balance in general
you know like that's not to say that i
never write the thing that i think is
just going to perform well there are
certain topic areas for me that i know
with a pretty high degree of certainty
or things that resonate with people that
they'll find interesting
i would say now i'm in the place where
like four out of five things that i post
are things that i am just super
interested in and wanting to write about
and think about
i will always always think about what is
the opening tweet to this that will grab
the most people and that will perform
well so i even if i'm writing something
that like i think is a more niche
esoteric topic i'll always try to have a
hook you know basically like the
equivalent of a you know a headline or a
thumbnail on youtube that will grab
people and the pushback against that is
like oh clickbait headline and my answer
is like yeah clickbait headline like i'm
trying to get people to read this i'm
not trying to have no one read it and if
that's what it takes to get people to
see the thing that i'm very proud of
that i put out then yeah i'm going to do
a clickbait headline and people are
going to click on it there's going to be
some people that get mad along the way
that's just how these things work and so
i i mean i would say i'm never putting
anything out that i'm not proud of and
that i don't think will benefit some
people but i'm always trying to make
sure that it gets seen because at the
end of the day that's the game we're
playing is like i get
i get no points for putting out
something that is amazingly well written
and so thoughtful and interesting that
50 people see no points and like am i
going to feel proud of that
that i wrote it maybe but that no one
saw it it's like what was the impact
that that had on the world so you know
like look i i posted this thing this
weekend of razers like the most
interesting razors like kind of decision
making heuristics it was the most viral
thing i've ever put out i think it's
like at 95 000 likes it did 25 million
impressions or something like that it
was
i don't know
75 stuff that i've already posted in the
past that i was able to like repackage
into something that had a much better
hook tightened it up like pulled it all
together in a more consistent storyline
but it wasn't all like brand new content
that i hadn't posted in the past it was
like super efficient from a time roi
perspective how i put it out and so i
think about this stuff a lot i would say
i'm generally probably not as strategic
as like i think there are tacticians
about this thing that like look at the
analytics on every word and how they
post different hooks i'm not like that
i'm more inspiration driven i never
create content in advance i mean i write
things
that morning and then post them like i
post once a week on twitter largely from
a thread perspective and i write it that
morning i'm not like i don't have a
repository of things that i'm gonna post
in the future so i can go both ways on
it that's generally how i've thought
about it though in the past we're just
gonna take a quick break from the
podcast to introduce the sponsor of this
episode which is very excitingly notion
if you watch any of my youtube videos
you have heard me talk about notion for
i think over three years now if you've
been living under a rock and you haven't
heard about notion by now it is this
sort of all-in-one collaborative
productivity tool that you can use
either personally or with a team and it
combines note-taking it combines like a
personal wiki it combines tables and
databases and tasks and calendars and
it's basically an all-in-one tool for
organizing almost anything in your
personal life or in your work life i
started using notion in like 2019 to
organize like all the stuff i was doing
in my medical life and my teaching and
then my youtube channel and now with our
team of around 20 people we are
basically all of us operate
asynchronously using various notion
databases and notion templates and so
much so much stuff of our life it just
revolves and lives inside notion and
it's just been an incredible tool for
helping us stay on the same page and
stay productive as a remote and
asynchronous team of 20 people now not
all work collaboration tools are created
equal obviously some of them help you
organize your company's information but
there's others that help you organize
just projects and tasks the nice thing
about notion is that it actually does
both and it's all in one tool which
makes it super easy to use and it's
beautifully designed which makes people
actually want to use it rather than kind
of shy away from wanting to use it
because it's just actually so well well
put together so whether you're a startup
trying to build a team like i am or if
you just want to organize your personal
productivity or maybe both and just want
to organize everything about your life
then definitely check out notion and if
you use the link in the video
description or in the show notes then
you will get some kind of promotion and
they'll know that we sent you and you'd
be supporting the podcast as well so
thank you so much notion for sponsoring
this episode yeah the the balance that
every what me and everyone else i know
struggles with as well i was chatting to
another
youtuber friend about this over dinner
last night and i was saying that like
you know my my dream youtube channel
involves one where i just make videos
about whatever i find interesting
and this friend was pushing back and
saying why not put the esoteric stuff on
a second channel and put the stuff that
you know is going to perform well on the
main channel because ultimately the main
channel is the nucleus of your business
and you know that and you kind of know
what's going to perform well on the main
channel it's going to be finance or
productivity or whatever
but if you want to take a foray into
like health and relationships which is
kind of outside of your niche
outside of your niche go second channel
so now you're still posting it you're
just posting it on a different platform
and there was something about that i was
like oh that feels like really good
advice but there's something about it
that feels a bit like
like i'm kind of giving something up by
even thinking about the different
platforms for like performance reasons
and stuff yeah i've rejected this
recently i mean i talked about the
fatherhood stuff and the content i've
been posting there i would say from the
early days my my
maybe this will help you or you'll have
some ideas that come from this from the
very early days my realization around
the longevity of twitter newsletter
podcast anything i did was that content
was eventually going to be automated
like ai is going to replace all written
content
video content like it's just as ais get
better and better people are going to be
able to produce all the things i write
via ai there's probably already an ai
that will put things into neval's voice
and like write an evolve thread without
him writing it so that the content will
already exist what you can't really
automate or ai at least in the near term
is personality and the feeling of
connection and affinity that you can
build with someone and so my perspective
from the early days was i want to build
a personality and a connection with my
audience a community with my audience
that they just care about the things
that i am finding interesting
and so that has manifested itself in a
few ways one my newsletter
i don't have like a specific thing i
write about i write about things that
are capturing my interest that i find
interesting that i'm learning at any
point in time and my newsletter is
really a journey of things that i'm
learning along the way my friday
newsletter in particular is like five
things that i found interesting during
the week that i'm gonna be sharing
similar to like what tim ferriss did and
i think did a really good job of it's
like thought the five bullet friday idea
i'm gonna share interesting things that
i'm learning on the journey similarly
with twitter recently it's manifest
itself and like i'm sharing more content
on fatherhood on parenting on my like
journey around wealth and what wealth
means to me and what enough means to me
recently i've done a lot around like
health and fitness something totally off
the path of like normally i write about
growth and productivity and you know
self-improvement et cetera and well i
was like well self you know
self-improvement health and fitness is a
huge part of that to me and i really
care about physical training i really
care about recovery stuff i like and so
i started posting you know things about
my like workout routine or mobility or
runs that i'm doing and it resonates
with some portion of my people and
they're building this level of
connection with me in a different way
and that has been my perspective is like
i'm just gonna share the things that i'm
getting excited about
if people aren't excited about those
that's fine i'm not the guy for them but
if i can build that like depth of
connection with a smaller subgroup of
the people that do follow me where they
want everything like anything i put out
they're like oh i gotta be going and
doing that running workout or i gotta go
build that habit that style is building
that's cool and that's what i really
want long-term and that's what i think
is durable long-term yeah i think i've
i've kind of landed at the same same
same conclusion that yeah what is the
youtube channel i would want tim ferriss
to have yeah
yeah every few days just makes a video
about whatever's on his mind and i
couldn't really care less i just i'm
just interested i like the thing to what
extent do you think this model of i will
share things i care about is a luxury
once you get big already versus a
strategy for even when you're quite
smaller and trying to break into the
twitter threadboy sphere or the
productivity youtuber sphere or whatever
other creator sphere people want to go
into i think it is a luxury i could say
otherwise i don't think i would be being
intellectually honest if i said
otherwise i think it's really i mean
like i think you can do it at a micro
level i think there's plenty of people
who do it at like a sub 1000 level where
you have like basically your friends and
friends of friends who find your life
very interesting and the things you're
doing and pursuing are interesting and
so you're getting this like micro
creator connection of someone curating
really interesting ideas or insights for
you i think it's probably really hard to
like grow a durable presence as that guy
because there's so many i mean like at
the macro level tim ferriss is probably
the biggest in the world of like he's
gonna go learn and do interesting things
and you're gonna be along for the
journey and he's gonna maybe write books
about it or do podcasts about it like
that's what he is and so you're not
gonna like beat him as you're trying to
come up along the way i mean look my
like goal if you were to define what i'm
trying to build like i want to be you
know the modern day or like you know
younger and maybe slightly less quirky
version of like tim ferriss james clear
shane parrish like some hybrid of these
people that i really admire and have
read and created you know and and
created around that's what i kind of
like doing like i'm sort of you know
shane parish has the like intellectual
angle i love that i learned a lot from
that tim ferriss has always had the body
angle i love that stuff passionate about
it you know james clear with all this
habit building self-improvement super
passionate about that i sort of feel
like where i am is kind of like this
hybrid of those different personalities
and building a you know a life in a in a
universe that's similar to what those
guys have done and kind of standing on
the shoulders of those giants a bit is
really my vision for it like i want to
write a book i want to like you know go
create more i want to speak more do
those kind of things and that's i mean
that's my vision for it now it's
interesting you say those names so
that's almost identical to what my
vision for my stuff is but like subtly
different so my sort of if i could
amalgamate like a future kind of
playbook career out of what people are
doing it's tim ferriss for the same
reason as you like actually it's it's
not really for the body reason it's more
like longevity of career reason and how
he just seems to post stuff that he
cares about and like he you know crypto
does well on his podcast but after a few
episodes he's like i don't care about
krypto anymore let me just post about
some like random random thing he seems
to just follow his own interests i would
add cal newport to the list because i
really vibe with the whole like academic
angle of like he's a tenured professor
and he teaches real students in real
life which seems fun and does the
reading the books and stuff on the side
and i'd probably go with derek sivers or
austin cleon on the list because i like
how they don't take themselves too
seriously and i think a lot of the other
people in this sphere are a bit too
serious and i want to be the sort of
light-hearted toilet jokes harry potter
references that kind of version of this
which is basically my personality just
like doubled up a little bit i love that
i think it's so interesting like i just
i'm i'm learning a lot from just
listening to you talk about these things
in the way that you're pursuing it but i
think it's so interesting to just try to
like archetype that way a little bit and
figure out you know what is your vision
and your real reality is you're going to
build your own version of all of these
things and a different perspective in a
different way that you grab people and
it's like i said right like tim ferriss
part of what has allowed him to do all
of what he's done is that he was making
smart investments along the way that he
was taking you know when when you make
the like 10 million a year from a big
book that you're eventually gonna do or
whatever it is you're gonna do where
you're gonna have one big thing it's
like what do you do with that you know
and how are you using that to establish
yourself for the long term so that you
can continue to do the interesting
things that make you unique and that
make you stand out for people long term
i mean clearly you've done that right
like you have a massive following on
youtube people clearly care about the
things that you're talking about and
doing and that's something to be super
proud of but i think that the focus on
longevity and the focus on the
durability of it that's what's going to
allow you to stand out because i just
think most people aren't thinking about
that they're like oh this is cool let me
like you know post more shirtless pics
on instagram whatever it is that'll
allow me to grab people for now but
there's always going to be someone
hotter there's always going to be
someone richer there's all you know like
all of those things are fleeting but
this connection and like intellectual
connection that you can have with your
community i i think that is really
durable that's why we still love tim
ferriss it's like you and i sitting here
20 or whatever 15 years after four hour
work week came out that's why we still
love him and we'll consume anything that
he puts out i've been thinking recently
around you know when people ask oh how
did how did your youtube channel succeed
amongst all the others and stuff and
it's it's easy to connect dots and
there's obviously survivorship buyers so
all of those caveats aside one thing
that i was sort of thinking from
basically day one is what does the
five-year longevity version what does
the 10-year longevity version of this
look like and i knew immediately that's
like okay i'm making content for medical
students that's got a sell-by date for
as long as i'm a medical student we need
to we need to do some reinventing like
very soon before just to try and stay
ahead of things and most other creators
who i know
like the ones who are huge think in
those terms are sort of like i want to
do this for the next like 10 plus years
the ones who are less huge tend not to
have gotten to that level of thinking
just yet and i think secondly like uh
one well one thing i've been thinking a
lot about is this question of like what
is the infinite game that i'm trying to
play here what is the thing that i'm
doing just for the sake of doing it and
the way i get to that is asking that
question of like you know if i want if i
won the euro millions and i had 100
million in the back like what would i be
doing okay that's my infinite game i
want to spend my time reading writing
learning teaching
cool once you're playing your infinite
game the only objective is to continue
playing and then things like uh what if
we double down and like triple the size
of the team and go big it's like
but like
that has a high risk because now it
increases our cost significantly and
it's not any it's like i'm still playing
my infinite game it's just like
it's
in a way it becomes asymmetrical
downside
trying to go too big once you're already
at your point where you're like spending
your time doing the things you care
about and like having having a nice life
i've wrestled with a lot of very similar
things i think one thing that durable
creators with long-term longevity will
do and it's something that i would
encourage everyone to think about as
their scaling is scale business outside
of your creator business so use the
creator business to build other
businesses that sit alongside it maybe
they're you know tangentially related to
the creator side of it but there are
other you know there there are other
pillars of business that are like real
enterprise value or at least real income
streams that are just outside of like
i'm earning money on youtube i'm earning
money from a newsletter i have like an
agency business that i created and
started which i don't really talk about
or write about but it's a pretty big
business now and it's very little time
from from from my perspective and you
know i have a couple people that work
for me it's very tight and it's an
example of exactly what you said if i
wanted to spend if i wanted to ramp that
up so let's you know let's say for for
even numbers let's say it's 100 a month
if i wanted to ramp that up to 200 what
would that require well if that requires
me
forexing the amount of time and mental
you know and headspace that i have to
spend on that that's really not worth it
to me like you know i would bring home
way more money great like i'd be
wealthier whatever it would mean but if
it means that i have to spend that much
more time on it that's actually not a
trade i want to make and so i'd rather
keep it small and keep it at the scale
that it's at and not have to go spend
all that extra time on it in order to do
it and that is something that i think is
a rewiring of your brain because when
you're coming from a traditional mindset
your mindset is like more more more i
gotta get every single dollar in my i'm
wired this way i have like an immigrant
mindset around this from you know from
my parents it's like i gotta get
everything i can get right now you know
like my dad is a tenured professor that
was like the ultimate income stream job
it's like it wasn't a wealth creation
job it was a income
and my wiring by nature was to like say
oh someone's willing to give me a
thousand dollars or something let me go
do that thing because i need to collect
every dollar i can get but that's
actually the wrong mindset for the long
term because what i really want to do is
like well right now this is a great
setup i don't have to spend a ton of
time on it generates a bunch of cash
flow i can walk into the other room
after this play with my kid for an hour
take him for a walk you know i can go
for walks in between calls and clear my
head make me more creative all of those
things are massively valuable to my life
just not in the way of money yeah i was
having a conversation with another
youtuber friend last week kind of
talking about this idea of like you know
people say that if you're not growing
you're dying and it's like
in a way that very oversimplified model
it can cause you to make a bunch of
decisions that you don't necessarily
want to make
but what this friend said was that
growth doesn't doesn't just have to be
in terms of revenue growth can in fact
be in terms of it requiring less time
from you and there was just something
about that framing of it that made me
think oh hello
yeah if i could sustain the same kind of
revenue and profit and have to spend
less time doing stuff i don't want to do
then actually we're winning and i would
i would take that over like doubling our
revenues at the expense of having to
spend more time thinking about stuff i
don't necessarily want to do anyway the
best business decision and the biggest
mental unlock i've ever made was
canceling a 10 000 a month client in my
agency business um and that was like a
year ago if you told me that i was going
to ever do something like that i would
have just told you to shut up because
that sounded crazy to me like you're
going to turn off something that you
know is like a great hourly rate like i
was probably spending i don't know 10
hours a month with that client it was
like an incredible hourly rate by any
stretch but it was causing me so much
stress and i was like it just wasn't
worth it and it was taking me away from
a bunch of other things and i so i ended
the contract and my life has been like
so much better since i did that and i'm
making less money on a monthly basis
because i removed it it ended up
allowing me to go and capitalize on a
few other opportunities that i know are
going to make me like probably 10x as
much in the long run
and it freed up my mind like during that
10 hours now i can write creatively i
can read more i can spend more time with
my son help my wife around the house
like it just has made my life better
doing that it was a huge mental barrier
for me to actually do that and now i
feel like really liberated from the from
the actual experience of doing it to be
able to think in that way more
comprehensively about time about value
about you know what your hourly rate is
where you'll actually want to take
something on and it really means i mean
it changes a lot when you first do that
yeah i actually had a similar moment
yesterday then this was the first time
i've made a decision like this where i
was just about to record a sponsor plug
for one of the youtube videos and they
were paying 15 grand yeah and it was a
product that i don't use and i was like
ugh
i could spend five minutes downloading
this and just doing the thing and it
would just take five minutes and five
minutes of my time for 15 grand it's a
pretty solid hourly rate but then there
was something about it that felt really
off and i was like no this is the point
where i have to make a decision so i
sent a message to the agency being like
sorry guys we're not we're not going to
do this deal because i don't use the
product i'll try it out in the next few
months and if i end up using it at some
point we can do a deal at some point but
sorry can we disappoint them and cancel
the deal and that suddenly felt like a
huge weight off my shoulders and now
that feels like in a way well in in law
once you have precedent for a thing then
you tend to kind of continue doing
things so now i have precedent that i
will genuinely only do sponsor plugs for
things i actually care about and there's
something about that like uh you know
i'm i'm now you know obviously that's a
privileged position to be in uh and i
would have probably made a different
decision even last year but just knowing
that i value authenticity more than like
cash is nice to know yeah you know it's
privileged but there's a seed of really
important insight there for anyone to
take away from this which is when that
happens when you have an experience like
that one thing i would encourage
everyone to do is like
write that down on a piece of paper
under you know core values or something
like that because i i've always found
that i have a tough time like defining
like if i were to sit down and you were
to tell me write down your 10 core
values i don't know what the hell i
would write that sounds really daunting
but when i experience something like
that and i draw a line in the sand on
something like that now i know like okay
that is one of my core values i'm not
gonna promote anything that i don't
genuinely use and benefit from i'm gonna
write that down on a piece of paper and
when you write that down now you're like
okay i'm starting to build that list of
things that i really care about and
maybe it's five maybe it's 10 maybe it's
20 eventually but now i know like i've
written it down that line in the sand
that i drew mentally i've now like
verbalized and really put it somewhere
and as that builds and compounds i've
just generally found that that makes a
huge huge difference because that like
it's written somewhere now it feels like
it's really cemented into you know how
you operate and how you do business with
people i really like that i've literally
just written that down like core values
list because i've done a bunch of these
exercises to try and figure out your
core values and i've never really vibed
with so hard and it's so hard to do i
think generally like uh structure is
like the enemy of progress on these
things like people are always you know
the big one for me has been journaling
like oh gratitude practice and
journaling and everyone's like oh you
have to journal and you have to do
gratitude practice you have to do all
these things and what i realized was
like if i tried to force myself into a
structure around any of those i just
didn't do it it was like oh now it feels
like a chore and i'm not going to do it
so what i did was i was like look my
daily gratitude practice is going to be
the hard line on it isn't going to be
that i'm going to
three things at the end of every single
day that i feel grateful for i can
either write them or i might just say
them in my head when i'm in the shower
before going to bed or lying in bed but
i'm gonna do that and that for me ended
up making all the difference in my life
like removing the feeling that i had to
sit down and write it down in a journal
suddenly it became very accessible for
me to do and it's made a huge difference
in my life but i personally think that
like having too much structure or making
something too challenging is holding
back so many people from these like
simple daily habits that would otherwise
really improve their lives one of one of
the the other kind of moments i have
around this core value stuff is i mean i
i did a bunch of like about five
different core values exercises they all
landed on freedom being like the
ultimate true core value and i was like
okay i mean that vibes with with
everything i know about myself but then
this time last year uh our accountant
and business advisors were suggesting
hey it's currently costing you a million
a year to live in the uk why not move to
dubai and i was like
okay interesting i sort of talked to
some lawyers talked about this a bunch
and i was like well if you do that to be
you have to become non-tax resident in
the uk and it's like that means like you
can only spend somewhere between 90 and
180 days in the uk every year i was like
ugh
that is
the the price of being in the uk is a
million plus a year but actually all my
friends are here my family is here i
actually do value the freedom to come
and go as i please and just hang out in
the uk even at the expense quote expense
of paying a million plus in in taxes
every year i was like yeah that's fine
that actually feels really good and that
cemented
yeah i actually do value freedom more
than more than a valley money which was
nice because before it was just a
theoretical thing but then i had like a
concrete example of like where that core
value made me make a decision that
someone else may not have chosen to make
or that i might have not made it under
different circumstances yeah i use like
twitter as my uh
my tracking system on some of these this
is a hill by the way that i'm willing to
die on the one you just said i'm you
know i lived in california for 12 years
from the time i went to college until
last summer until july 2021 when my wife
and i moved to new york uh to be mainly
to be closer to family i have so many
friends like you know wealthy friends
that have sold companies or done
whatever and they're like oh why did you
move from the highest tax state in the
country to the second highest tax state
in the country like why didn't you move
to florida or texas or you know one of
these zero income tax you would have
saved a lot of money and my answer was
always like yes i would have you know
objectively saved money on taxes but to
what end like i have no family there i
don't have friends that live in these
places maybe a couple but like have you
ever been to florida in the summer not
not super nice like you know 100 degrees
and super humid every single day same
with texas like i'm in new york i'm
close to family i get to see them all
the time i'm super willing to pay a tax
uh you know like friction cost for
having the life that i want to live
around these things and that means a lot
to me and that's worth way more than the
taxes i'm gonna save by moving on to one
of these other places yeah i've i
realized that sort of trade of like
money versus
vibes recently as well because
again some some of the youtuber friends
i was speaking to was saying that why do
you have employees in person like why do
you have employees in the uk in the uk
you have to pay their pension and their
insurance and they want work-life
balance why not hire people abroad where
you can pay them less money and then you
just be on zoom calls with them and i
was like
yeah but it's just less fun and it's
like i really i really like hanging out
with people i like people
yeah it's fun it's fun hanging out with
people i don't particularly enjoy being
on zoom calls all day but i do enjoy
hanging out with people all day and so
yes it's more expensive and maybe not
the best quote business decision but
like the point of the business is
instrumental in helping me live the life
that i want to live while also having
the impact that i want to have in that
little overlapping venn diagrammy bit so
it's not really fine i will die on the
hill of working with people in real life
is way more fun than overzoom and i mean
creative like the creator economy one of
the most challenging parts as a creator
is the loneliness of it i'm sure a lot
of your youtuber friends that are like
sort of coming up like they haven't
built the business around themselves yet
it's just them
i'm sure a lot of them deal with this
where it's like you're on your own man
and you're having to create constantly i
mean like i don't know what youtube is
like i imagine it's this way where you
just feel like you know you have to
create on a consistent case you know two
videos a week whatever the number is and
you're having to come up with new ideas
you're having to post them and create
good videos and you're stressing when
the video doesn't perform as well and
you're feeling good when it does and it
impacts your mood and it's lonely man if
you're on your own
it is lonely um and i you know i'm
fortunate with twitter in that like i
sort of got out like got out of the
phase where i needed to do that before
it became hyper competitive like now
twitter there's so many people writing
you know i mean threads have become a
whole meme and you know there's so many
people writing the same threads and it's
just it's a market right it's like
anything else where like if you're early
to a market which i was i was like
probably the first person that was
really writing threads consistently you
benefit the most and you gotta get out
in front then it becomes much more
competitive and so it's challenging and
now like if you're in there it's
challenging you're having to do more
cringe things to like try to grow and uh
you know posting whatever and it's like
that on youtube too i imagine where like
the people that were doing it
consistently early on scaled and did
really well
and people that are trying to like go
start now and build it's more
competitive like you're really having to
figure out new ways to stand out and so
having a team around you and people to
help you with that like emotional and
mental side of that struggle i think
it's again it's like you'd pay for that
like it's worth paying for because it
means something to your mental state i'd
love to go back to something we talked
about um a bit earlier in the
conversation and this idea of default
alive from a personal finance
perspective i guess easy enough on the
path well uh it is now kind of [ __ ] you
know i've been doing this for a while
for us to for us to be at that point but
i wonder if you were speaking if you
were to if you were speaking to let's
say uh someone who's at university or
just about to graduate or has just
graduated you know so let's say someone
in their early 20s going into their
first job who's like listening to this
and thinking you know what this default
a live thing sounds pretty good this
financial freedom thing sounds pretty
good what would be your like playbook
how would you go about kind of getting
to that point from the point i've got a
bunch of friends who started finance
careers or like worked
in mckinsey or something how would you
approach that yeah that journey so
for people that aren't familiar with the
reference paul graham the founder of y
combinator has this essay called default
alive or default dead which you can look
up and it was in reference to startups
and it was about you know startups are
either default alive or their default
dead and what he meant was that like if
you stop growing and you just kind of
run out the current expense load and the
kind of current growth rate or whatever
the revenue is that's coming in will you
you know be able to self-sustain or will
you eventually just run out and die and
i read it and you know it's interesting
as it applies to startups and sort of a
bible for startups during recession
times like right now but i think it's
more interesting to think about as it
relates to yourself like you want your
own personal situation to be default
alive and so like what would my playbook
be i mean if i were starting out i would
say the first thing is the systems point
which is figure out like what are your
income streams and if you're going to
get your one core job that's obviously
going to be your first income stream i
personally think that like figuring out
a way to build and create
certain i think passive income is a
little bit of a misnomer that's become a
meme like no income is truly passive
i've never had passive income in my
whole life there's always something to
do but creating you know some sort of
side hustle income that allows you to
augment that in the early years i think
it's a great time to do that like just
figure out how to set up certain things
you know whether that's online income
whether it's like frankly you know doing
a little like side hustles consulting
services et cetera figure out what your
skills are and how that you how you can
sell those for more than what they cost
you from a time perspective and create
that income base live frugally in the
early years i think is like a huge huge
advantage everyone that i know that did
that i wouldn't say anyone regrets it
like people that just lived within their
means you know make sure you're saving
money every month and take that money
and put it into things that compound and
you know i
in general think that like money you
know you should just be thinking about
investing and compounding in everything
you do and i think that's knowledge i
think that's career skills and it's
definitely money and for me that's like
do the basics like put money into a zero
cost um you know etf or mutual fund that
is just going to kind of track the
market don't try to outsmart the market
and be the like genius investor don't
fall victim to the like fomo and your
friend has some like oh this is 10x with
no risk or this is like 20 yield
annually no risk it's just like just
avoid it you know i've lost money on
plenty of those things just trust me
it's like
anything that sounds too good to be true
definitely is so i think it's just doing
the basics like
you will if you are getting a stable job
and if you're kind of like thinking
about and building you know augmenting
that income along the way if you're
living frugally and if you're investing
that money everyone can be a millionaire
by the time they're you know in their
mid-30s like it's just it the math just
works out if you you know if you live
that way and so i that that's what i
would encourage people to start with and
like if you're living that way and
you're living frugally i think it's a
huge advantage the other thing i would
say is like if you are going to scale up
your lifestyle which like look i'm
sitting here i'm in a nice house you're
like i have done those things i've
scaled up my lifestyle as i've as i've
done better i'm always careful to know
what can i scale back
and if i need to there are things that i
can pull back on like you know different
things about our life where i'm like hey
this wouldn't impact my life in any
material way for me to like cut back on
this cost you know maybe it's that i
like to take you know uber black instead
of uberx it was a stupid thing but like
you know to get home from the city when
it's late or if i want to work in the
car i'll do a more expensive uber or
like maybe i'll take the train instead
of ubering that'll save me a bunch of
money every week or maybe like instead
of that really nice you know dinner that
i like to take a client out to maybe
it's something slightly cheaper but
there's ways that like you think about
in your own mind of like okay if i need
to i can cut back on this this this and
this and having those levers in your
mind it just creates like a stress
reduction that is really beneficial to
to how you live on a daily basis it's
just like this peace of mind that brings
a level of calm to the rest of your life
okay a bunch of questions on that front
observation on this point around cutting
back things i like to think i mean
these days i definitely live live within
my means but i've had a lot of lifestyle
creep over the last like year or two
especially as the business has
skyrocketed and i decided i was going to
move to london if i'm moving to london i
might as well bang in the middle of
central london and like the nicest and
it's you know all that kind of stuff and
then i i find that like depending on
what my information diet is i feel
differently about this so i was
listening to an episode of my first
million where they were interviewing
neil patel and talking about like crazy
250 000 a a month like burn rate in like
insulin full-time full-time housekeeper
driver i was like bloody hell that
part of me was thinking oh my god part
of me was thinking that sounds kind of
cool but then i watched a friend a video
yesterday of another youtuber friend of
mine called olier who made a video how
much money he spends in a year and i was
like it was like 40 grand a year yeah
and he was like yeah you know i just
live with a basic 40 grand salary and
this guy's making like 800k a year of
his youtube channel and like could
easily make more but he's like living in
a pretty chill life does whatever he
wants and does it on 40k a year and i
was like wow and in a way like the more
of those sorts of people that i see the
people that are living
frugally relative to the ridiculous
income that they have the more i feel
very satisfied with my current situation
of like actually yeah this feels good
but whenever i speak to someone who's
like in the 10 million plus range and
they're talking about like
how they fly private because it's it's
good roi and stuff then i start thinking
oh maybe i should be trying to grow the
business i i find myself sort of pulled
in
in in different directions i always feel
like i have to come back to the center
of like no let's return to the thing
that i actually care about reading
writing learning teaching i don't need
lots of money to do that yeah and
anytime i try and chase more of it it
just adds more pressure to making
youtube videos which like hampers
creativity and it just leads to bad
things happening when i try and over
optimize for yeah growth and stuff the
one thing i would say as a broad point
any time and i don't know this person
but anytime someone boasts or brags
about their level of wealth or success i
tend to assume that it is about you know
one half of what they say i just think
that like
real true ultra successful people don't
really ever brag about their success or
their wealth and so like i just tend to
assume that they're lying or
exaggerating to a significant degree
it's like a schoolyard rule of thumb um
but yeah i've generally found that it to
be true i'm personally just like i'm
generally super turned off by people
that you know brag about how they're
doing and their wealth and like the
things that they're doing and how
they're like flying uncertain i just
like i don't really care like are you
happy
you know are you interesting like i'd
rather talk to my uber driver who has
like some interesting backstory in life
than to some like you know rich guy
who's really showy with his wealth and
you know flexes on me by telling me how
much he spent on certain things just me
maybe other people feel differently
that's just my perspective and then look
i mean my framework for thinking about
all this stuff is i love to live in a
way where when i want to spend money on
something and i s and i see it i don't
need to worry about it and think about
it and the way that you do that is by
living well within your means in normal
times like you know i want to live in a
way where i'm making you know great
money because hopefully i'm creating a
bunch of value for the world and for
other people and i'm living on a normal
day-to-day basis quite frugally and like
we're super happy i have you know
everything i can want kid is healthy
which is the only thing that matters in
the world you know family's healthy etc
and if i end up seeing some like cool
vacation or i want to go do something or
i want to like get a new you know gym
thing for the backyard and it's
expensive i literally don't need to
think about it because i know that my
normal course life is like cheap and
saving tons of money every month and
like if i want to buy some pair of shoes
that i really have wanted and they're
expensive i used to be in a state when i
was working in finance where i was
literally like month to month i was
making a bunch of money but i was month
to month like i'm not really saving much
money every single month and i was
basically living to what my salary was
because of the lifestyle i was living
and then when something would come up
and there would be like oh this you know
nice bachelor party and it was going to
be expensive it would stress me out
because i'd be like oh man that's going
to put me over i'm actually going to
lose money this month now i'm in a spot
where i'm like i'm actually not spending
anywhere near as much as what i was and
as what were
what i'm making from a business
standpoint and so then when the thing
comes up i can feel like excited about
it it doesn't stress me out i can just
get this thing because i'm like really
looking forward to it or we can go on
that little vacation because and it
feels exciting and not stress inducing
and i think that is a huge huge deal
when you're able to actually go and like
buy the thing or um go on the trip or go
invest in the thing and feel excited
about it because it is exciting and not
stressed because it's like pushing you
to the limit that's a big big
improvement from a lifestyle standpoint
something a lot of people say and i
often say to young young younger people
as well as an old dude that like this
this idea of augmenting your income for
because you know having being being
reliant on a single source of income is
not particularly anti-fragile as they
say and it's worth like i don't know
anyone who has ever regretted having a
side hustle to augment their income like
it's always a thing that people are
really glad for but then there's often
like you know when
when encouraging friends to do this
there will often be a little bit of a
pushback of like yeah but you know when
i get home from work i'm super tired and
i know i need two hours of netflix to
unwind and then i know i want to do my i
don't know go to the spa and chill there
for an hour and i know i want to talk to
my family for an hour and then that then
it's time for bed and it's time to time
to sleep and start the day and start the
day fresh and i don't want to be working
on the weekends because like work-life
balance and stuff and i'm always like
okay fair enough if that if that's what
you've decided that you want to do with
your life then great you know you do you
as long as as long as you're happy
that's fine but in the back of my mind
i'm always kind of thinking do you
really need those two hours of netflix
like will your future self not be more
glad if you actually didn't spend that
time watching netflix and instead spent
that time learning how to code building
a website then i think am i just some
hustle bro productivity bro who's just
like over indexed on everyone should
have a side hustle what do you reckon i
have a lot of thoughts on this i mean
look i i think in general everyone has
to figure out what works for them and
their life and what makes them happy to
the way that you said it i tend to think
that most people actually work a small
fraction of the amount of time that they
think they're working you know like i
worked in a mainstream office right like
i was there i worked 90 hour weeks how
many of those hours were spent like
browsing
espn.com or you know on you know on the
wall street journal or whatever because
i was like waiting for some work to come
in and you just find ways to fill time
it's called parkinson's law it's like
work finds a way to expand to the amount
of time allotted for it and so you know
that you have to be at work from nine to
five for the entire week you just find a
way to fill that it's not that you're
doing productive work for eight hours a
day no one does that it's impossible to
focus for eight hours a day it's
literally like physically scientifically
impossible and so my thing is always
like a
i don't really believe that most people
need the two hours to like unwind from
that during the day because you were
sort of unwinding during the day in some
way you know whether you were like
browsing things or took a lunch break or
whatever it was and b i think there's
like just a better way to work in that
context and like if you can find a way
during your work day to work in you know
60 minute blocks of like true focus and
then go take a walk or like
you know relax or do something that is
different during a you know separate
period read something that is improving
you etc i think you can find ways to
like hack the normal work life so that
you're actually making progress in other
arenas if you want to and if what you
decide will make you happy will be you
know having a de-risked financial
situation by having multiple streams of
income by being more anti-fragile then i
think you can do that without saying
that i need to come home and work for
five hours a night or work five hours
every weekend day the other thing that i
would say is that like generally side
hustles need to be something that you
actually care about and like want to go
do
you can you know i know people who have
like done a side hustle as an uber
driver doordash or whatever it is i
think you can do that it's not ever
going to be great leverage on your time
it's just the reality of it the best
leverage on your time is going to be
things that you have a skill at that you
can sell to someone for more than what
they cost you to provide and like
whether that's online you know you
create a course and you're selling it
it's infinitely scalable or if it's like
services like hey i'm you know really
good at building financial models
because i work in finance well there's a
lot of startups that will pay you like
10 grand to go make a financial model
and if you can figure out a way to sell
your services to those people you can go
make a lot of money like i i know i
found a bunch of those startups and i
was helping people get it i was taking
like clipping a fee for connecting them
with financial analyst at one point like
i was hustling doing that but there's a
huge market for that that like
investment banking analysts if you
wanted to work a little more on the
weekend and like build a model because
you kind of enjoy it you could make way
more than what your hourly rate is from
your investment making job by doing that
so that's i mean like i just generally
think there's an infinite number of
opportunities out there and the reality
is that opportunity is not what's
lacking what's lacking is people that
are willing and able to go and
capitalize on those opportunities yeah i
really like that dreaming of it we're in
the middle of one of our cohorts for
part-time youtuber academy cool at six
at the moment and people always ask
repeatedly hey how did you manage to do
the youtube channel thing while working
as a doctor yeah and my answer is always
like well hey i've been answering this
for the last like five years but happy
to continue doing it if because
i mean it's obvious to me but it seems
to still be novel to other people but it
was always that like you know even
working a 60 hour week as a doctor yes
yes there are some days that are like
back to back chocolate block but most
days there's like some amount of down
time you know you've got to ring
radiology and you've got to wait five
minutes on the phone because they're on
the phone there's a cue you can't really
do anything else because you
you've got to call radiology so in that
time i'd just be opening up notion on my
shitty windows computer at work and just
planning out a video or you wait five
minutes because a patient's gone to the
toilet and you need to wait for them to
take the blood there's always like
little bits of down time here and there
where one option is use flick through
instagram or twitter and the other
option is you open up notion or apple
notes and draft out your next video and
that's that's the way i hacked
even a workday as a doctor which you
know most people are not saying they're
browsing espn but like they are waiting
around for something or other to happen
and tend to be writing instagram instead
yeah i mean i only realized this when
kovit hit like i mean i was in the
office a lot or traveling a lot and i
only realized how much
actual like work hours to down hours i
had when i wasn't in the office and so
like the work kind of became more
transactional and so i was going from
thing to thing and realized that the
like friction time in between stuff was
actually totally free and i had just
been finding ways to fill it with random
stuff that wasn't necessarily productive
and so that was a big unlock for me
personally but yeah i mean i like i've
now found that like my best thinking
business thinking creative work etc
comes on like a walk or while i'm
driving in silence in the car or in the
shower or something so i mean i just i
literally just carry little notebooks
around with me everywhere i go i tend to
not use my phone um when i'm walking so
i carry these little notebooks around
and just write stuff down and they tend
to have like all of my best ideas or
sketches or whatever it is that i'm
working on i like that thing that you
said around you
something along the lines of your side
hustle needs to be something you
actually enjoy a good friend of mine is
a sort of sort of baby youtuber actually
you know like somewhere between 10 and
20k subs and
she's been doing it for like a year and
a bit that kind of thing and one thing
that she says is that like the youtube
videos are kind of fun but like she
doesn't enjoy it as much as i seem to
and she's like well i could take this
more seriously but i'd really only be
doing it for the potential for money
further down the line and i'm not
inherently interested in the thing
whereas i think for me i was lucky
because i picked a thing that i was
inherently interested in how important
do you think it is to genuinely enjoy
the side hustle you're doing versus
treat it more like instrumental for the
sake of building some amount of
financial freedom further down the line
i think there has to be a level of
intrinsic motivation from from joy that
you get from it the reason i say that is
just because there's two sides to this
right there's like intensity and there's
consistency i think that money can
create intensity like i think that you
can see like oh i'm going to make a
million dollars this year and it's going
to make me focus a ton i'm going to
really grind it out and you know put in
all these hours and do this i'm going to
get the bonus or i'm going to make my
youtube channel big whatever but the
consistency and your ability to show up
every single day when you feel good when
you don't feel good when you're tired
when it's a holiday when your family has
something and you have to miss it like
that consistency only comes from
enjoying it and from wanting to be a
part of it and enjoying the process
around it and enjoying the ups and downs
like it's not always going to be good
you're going to put things out you're
proud of and they're not going to go
anywhere you're going to get punched in
the face haters are going to tell you
they want you to go burn in a house you
know like all that stuff the consistency
only comes from enjoying it on the way
and like i you know i will say this
until the cows come home the biggest
driver of my success in anything in life
has always been that i am consistent
baseball i was never the most talented
never going to be the most talented but
i was just going to show up every single
day and just come at you over and over
and over again and it's really hard to
beat someone that does that like it's
just very hard to durably beat someone
that just keeps getting up keeps showing
up and i felt that way when i took you
know my approach to twitter was like i
might not write the most viral post ever
i've still
you know never had a post that goes over
i mean now i just had my biggest one
ever but never had something go over 100
000 likes i see people putting out like
10 excel tips and it goes over 100 000
likes and it's crazy me like i've never
done that but i have written something
on twitter every single week you know
since may of 2020 and i would stack that
consistency up against anyone in the
world that has you know been around
during that period and so people are
like oh what's the hack you know how did
you grow to this big i'm like well the
hack is that i wrote 250 000 words on
twitter over the course of the last two
years like that's the hack i spent you
know thousands of hours writing on the
weekends you know while people were out
doing fun stuff like i just i enjoyed it
and i got energy out of it and so i
wanted to keep doing it i think you have
to enjoy it in order to do that because
otherwise i would have just been
miserable i would have been at home
writing you know working long hours
because i was trying to balance it
against my day job until i ended up
doubling down on this and
the enjoyment is so key to creating that
consistency when it comes to this
enjoyment to what extent do you think
it's
finding something you enjoy versus
finding enjoyment in the thing if you go
if you forget what i'm trying to say i
think it's the latter actually you know
and i've never really thought about the
characterization there i personally i
don't think you know whether you enjoy
something until you really get into the
weeds on it like if i waited to only
pursue things that i thought i was
passionate about at the outset if i just
didn't pursue anything because i wasn't
passionate about it i think i would have
missed a lot of really cool things along
the way i just think you don't realize
you're passionate about something until
you get into the weeds like i didn't
know i was passionate about writing i
had one idea on to to write this thing
on twitter like it was may 12th 2020. i
was out on a walk and i had this idea
come to me and i was like man i really
want to write this one thing i wasn't
passionate about writing on twitter i
wrote this one thing it picked up
because it was clear that it came across
it resonated and so then i was like oh
there was something to that let me write
another thing and as i started doing it
i realized i was getting a lot of energy
from the writing and from the research
and from learning about it but i didn't
like set out saying i love writing
things on twitter i didn't even consider
myself a writer i didn't think of myself
as someone that loved writing and along
the way i found this immense love for
writing immense love for like sharing
you know self-improvement or
productivity knowledge or different
insights around these things and you
know that was what the big unlock was
for me and so i think it's though i
really do think it's the latter it's
like you know you find an enjoyment in
something as you pursue it and that only
comes from trying things and so like i
think if there's one lesson to take away
from it it's to go
experiment try things you know and be
quick to
switch like test and learn very quickly
and try things and like double down on
the things you really enjoy and that you
learn and that you're that you're
growing around yeah i've i i totally
agree this is in fact the thesis of the
book that i'm writing where it's like
the secret to sustainable productivity
really is to find a way to make what
you're doing already find out find a way
to make it more energizing
i think it's a question of like
does this thing currently give me energy
and if not can i pull on the various
levers that we know from the science and
the research and stuff that
tend for most people to correspond to
stuff being energizing you know power
play people autonomy mastery purpose all
these other things i'm in the process of
writing about all of that stuff is stuff
that really can apply to almost anything
that we're doing because the whole the
whole thing of like follow your passion
and is is sort of a bit of a thing
that's reserved for people with
decent amounts of privilege to be able
to spend all day playing the guitar
which is the thing that i truly enjoy
but there's
what i found is that like
with the youtube channel with the
podcast with writing with medicine with
random stuff at university with anything
i've done the more i've lent into the
stuff that's within those specific
things
fills me with energy rather than drains
my energy and the more i've been able to
sort of use that as a guiding framework
for like is this energizing is it
draining if not make it more energizing
the more it's just felt like
i'm operating on like easy mode because
nothing feels like i'm pushing a boulder
up the hill and it never feels like i
need to use discipline to put out a
youtube video because i'm just doing the
bits that are energizing and i'm just
not doing the bits that are not yeah
it's an interesting it is a really
interesting framing i do think things
you have to give things time to get to
easy mode like my newsletter i would say
for the first nine months i mean i've
only been doing it for i guess 14 months
now but for the first like 9 or 10 it
really felt like it was on hard mode i
would say only in the last couple months
have i felt like oh my god this is fun i
really enjoy this this feels easy for me
it feels like flow state when i'm doing
it and that's cool it's cool when you
feel that that something all of a sudden
becomes easy i always like i use a lot
of like sports or fitness analogies but
there was this hill i started running
earlier this summer because it was nice
out i hadn't ran like really in my whole
life i was like this is a thing it's
good for me i'd like to be outside let
me try it so i started running and there
was this hill near my house i'm a very
competitive person i ran up it i told
myself i was going to run up this hill
and i ran up and i was gassed like
completely dead you know had to stop
couldn't really make it up the whole
hill and i was like man screw that like
is that hill like that was so hard that
that happened so what i said was like
i'm gonna run up that hill every single
day for the next 30 days and i don't
care like whether i feel good or not i'm
just going to run up it every day for 30
days and i just finished that 30 days
and yesterday i went out for a run and
that hill was right at the end and i ran
up the hill and i like got to the top
and felt great and i was like man i just
complete like in the span of 30 days
that hill went from being like a nemesis
like i thought i was gonna die feeling
fresh and running up it to like it was
like my dessert at the end of this run i
ran up and felt totally good and it's
like it's a powerful metaphor in there
of like 30 days is really all it takes
sometimes to go from feeling like you
know beginner mode to expert mode on
something i mean it's just dedicated
effort consistently applied yeah i love
that it takes time to get from hot mode
to easy mode yeah
that's very good yeah so a few things
are easy mode from day one and if they
are it sort of feels a bit suspect yeah
that little bit of like discomfort in
the early stages generally i find like
if i think back to youtube channel early
days where it was like a struggle to
edit there was that feeling of like oh
nice i've i've got i've i vanquished
this beast at the end of it so i got a
little bit of like a dopamine head out
of like yes it felt like a lot of work
to do this thing but i'm glad like maybe
i wasn't happy while doing it but i
definitely felt fulfilled afterwards and
then over time i got started to get
happy during the editing thing and
then i started to appreciate the craft
itself rather than viewing it purely as
an obstacle to overcome to do the thing
i actually wanted which was to get the
video out
so i have a question for you on this
general topic so i have i don't know
zero subscribers on youtube i don't know
what my actual number maybe i have like
five effectively zero but i do think
that i have a lot of really interesting
written content that would make some
amazing videos like just taking the
written content turning them into videos
that i could kind of talk about narrate
over et cetera you know i've been told
maybe that i have a face for radio but i
think i could manage it what advice
would you have if if i were going to
pursue it like it's terribly daunting to
me because i have zero videos 21
subscribers i just checked big big
subscriber count 3.19
million away from you so like what what
advice would you give to someone that
was you know in my shoes you have a
bunch of content etc like try it don't
try it you know dedicate you have to
dedicate a ton of time to it how would
you think about it loads to unpack i
would think about it in the sense of
there's three levels level one level two
level three level one is get going level
two is get good and level three is get
smart and in between these different
levels you have a choice that you need
to make so level one is get going that's
just so what i'd say to you or anyone
else in this position is just make five
videos and see what happens just like
don't overthink it what would this look
like if it were easy do the tim ferriss
thing take one of your tweets like
literally just even on this very setup
you have with a podcast with a
microphone just like just chat through
it because you're good at talking and
you know all that stuff and see how it
feels
five videos in at that point you have a
decision to make of like
do i want a casual relationship with
youtube or do i want a serious
relationship with youtube serious
meaning am i gonna commit to doing this
consistently casual being like i'll post
i'll click my i'll send this any time i
do a podcast i'll send a i'll send the
video to my uh announcements editor and
they'll just chuck clips of me on that's
like casual because you're not really
taking it seriously sirius is like i'm
gonna commit to it beyond
once you've decided that it's serious at
that point it's get good which is like
okay let's actually get good at making
videos let's see like what does it take
to make a good video title thumbnail
hook blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
let's do my production value stick a
light in the background stick a plant in
the background figure out what i want to
do and at some point and i think this
will happen pretty quickly for you
because you are pretty experienced in
this content stuff your videos will be
quote sufficiently good that you don't
cringe at them and you'll start to see
some level of traction again going to
happen quicker for you because you've
got stupidly large audience on twitter
so you can always transition some
audience from twitter to youtube now
once you're once you're at the point
where you're not cringing at your videos
anymore at that point they're good
enough and now most of the gains i mean
improving at youtube is a lifelong
endeavor of course but now most of the
gains are going to come from getting
smart and at that point the question is
on the spectrum do i want to treat this
like a hobby or do i want to treat this
like a business
and the more on the business the end of
the spectrum you are the more you then
start doing the things that a startup
would do market research competitor
analysis how are you going to stand out
what's your niche going to be who is
your you know interviewing target
audience and like figuring out what what
people want looking at analytics and
trends and all that jazz looking at
other other people in your niche's viral
videos to see if you can replicate their
performance and their success and do it
but do it in your own way and you start
to get into all of those like
business strategy parts of youtube but i
think the mistake people make is they
overthink their niche they overthink
like what what's my target audience
what's my niche like i don't want to
make videos about that which is sort of
like a level three thing while they're
at level like level zero or level one
and they haven't started making any
videos yet so i think you could
absolutely bang on youtube to be honest
but a big part of it is because you
don't need it so it's really a case of
do you enjoy doing the thing you seem
pretty natural and confident on camera
so i think it's it's definitely worth
trying interesting super super helpful i
appreciate all the all the perspectives
and the idea of just like outsourcing
the whole thing what do you think about
people doing that like you know paying a
bunch of money like you know it costs a
lot honestly like the people that have
quoted me on doing this you know two
four videos a month whatever it's super
expensive but they'll be really high
production value from the get-go because
you're you know giving it to people that
really know it what do you think about
that i think with reasonable i think
you cannot outsource the writing of your
own video totally i have tried so hard
it's important basically impossible to
do and everyone's spoken to really
really really struggle with this unless
you're like a vox media or a wendover
productions where you're researching
scripts and it's not a personality but i
suspect you want to be a personality
channel yeah but if you i mean
absolutely outsourcing the editing to
make it look slick would be
absolutely complete totally reasonable
but there's no getting away from the
fact that you actually have to do the
work yourself and that work brought me
in the writing but you're all right so
you'll probably tell about that all
right well cool i have a couple other
questions and oh yeah afterwards send
you free access to all of my courses
about this so if you are interested you
can just amazing content creators i
appreciate it and basically download my
brain into yours if you want to do the
youtube thing how do you make money
these days man this is going to be a
long conversation
yeah so i i mentioned i have the kind of
agency advisory business you know that's
broadly speaking helping startups with
social and content like narrative really
narrative and storytelling you know and
that's mostly across written content
mostly like twitter newsletter you know
have a few writers on staff and you know
helping with strategy execution and
amplification of content that kind of
you know is a is a pretty
self-sustaining business i have my fund
which is a 10 million venture fund that
i invest in early stage technology
companies 100 to 250k checks you know
that's really a long-term wealth
creation vehicle you know i take a
percentage of it
10 million from are you getting lp's is
it to or is it yeah so i did a
traditional fund not a rolling fund so i
have
three anchor lps that are kind of larger
checks and then a long list of you know
really like some institutions and high
net worth individuals a lot of that was
because i had spent my first seven years
of my career in in high finance and so
had a lot of relationships and you know
lps etc from my private equity days that
uh you know that i was able to go talk
to and kind of tell the story of what i
was going to go build when did you make
the fund january 2022 so just a few
months ago
yeah yeah so how did you just like if i
wanted to make a fun can i just make a
fun like how the hell does that work i
know i know i know basically nothing i
don't don't even know what else to start
with so like i'm a complete beginner to
this so angel list as a as a platform
makes it very easy to go create a fund
you could do it a couple of different
ways you could do a syndicate which is
people can kind of subscribe to see
deals that you're looking at and then
they can on a deal-by-deal basis decide
whether to invest in something that is
economically the best way for you to do
it because then you get carried interest
so like percentage of the profits on a
deal-by-deal basis rather than across an
entire fund so you know having a dud
doesn't matter because it's just like on
an individual deal or you can do a
rolling fund which would be you know
basically people subscribe to your fund
on a quarterly basis and a minimum
amount you can publish that on youtube
or on twitter or wherever your channels
are and people could who want to kind of
like invest alongside you because they
believe in the things you're doing and
the value you create they could invest
alongside you i did a traditional fund
which means you can't market it on
twitter you cannot market it publicly i
did that mainly because i had the
relationships and you know lp interest
that i didn't need to at the time i
think in future i would open it up so
that more people would come into future
funds and i would market it more broadly
so that other people could could invest
alongside me but for this first one i
wanted to kind of keep it pretty tight
in how i uh and how i pursued it okay
this sounds pretty cool i'm i'm gonna
need to ask you more questions about
this rolling phone at some point you've
got this fund you decided in january
you're gonna make a fund you've raised
10 million dollars from like people that
you just knew because you worked in
finance for like ages and now you invest
in companies and you give them 100k to
250k and you're hoping that over time
some of them will become the next stripe
and return the fund is is that the idea
or yeah stripe would be great i would i
would i would i would not be doing any
more uh any more podcasts if one of them
turns into strife no yeah i mean
generally speaking it's like pre-seed
and seed investing so you're investing
at valuations between
10 and you know maybe 5 million and 25
million dollars and you know the goal is
that you're you know seeing some of
those become billion dollar companies
and so you know you're seeing 25 you
know turn into a couple billion dollars
and those companies go public or they're
acquired and you know the 100k that you
put in becomes worth 10 million dollars
in a you know in a great outcome and
100x outcome and you know the general
goal is that you kind of you know 5x the
value of the fund so you turn 10 million
dollars into 50 i would say would be
like a supreme amazing outcome 10x would
be like astronomical you know you turn
10 million into 100 you know 23x is like
average probably and you've done okay
but the whole goal is that you're you
know delivering outsized returns to your
investors and then you get a percentage
of the profit so i take 25 of the
profits that i generate so if i 5x the
fund i take 10 million dollars back from
that yeah that's pretty cool yeah for
okay from from what you know this is a
bit of a subject question from from what
you know about like what i do on on
youtube and stuff do you think it's
reasonable for me to think about doing a
rolling fund yes yeah i mean this is
very broadly like in line with my thesis
on where the world is heading and so
like i'm more than happy to catch up
with you more on this and you know give
you kind of more of a playbook around it
as well because my general perspective
is that we've had this like barbell that
has formed around the investing
landscape within early stage companies
and what's happened is you have the like
really high name brand venture funds on
one end you know the sequoias andreessen
horowitz you know tiger global some of
these like really big brand name funds
that when they invest it's a huge marker
to say like wow stamp of approval on
this company amazing investors and then
there's this like wasteland of like kind
of like mid-tier vcs that it's very it's
been very unclear for a long time what
is their value add and a lot of them do
have like very clear value add so i
don't want to you know dunk on them
they're great but a lot of them don't
and a lot of them are just like a vc
that's managed to raise some money and
their performance isn't great and it's
unclear what value they're going to
bring to the company that they invested
in then on the other end of this barbell
you have people like me who have one
very clear lever of value that they can
bring to you for me that's like i'm
gonna get eyes on what you're doing and
you know amplify things that you're
putting out when you're announcing
things when you're making announcements
i can create a video when you you know
announce your fundraise that's going to
get tons of eyes on what you're doing
it's going to help with you know
customers fundraising recruiting etc and
that is super valuable and for a small
check size it's really easy for me to
make the case that i should be invested
in the company and the whole game is you
need to see the best deals and then you
need those companies to want you to
invest because they can take money from
anywhere and if they have a 10 million
dollar fundraising round there's a
hundred million of demand for that 10
million and you need to make sure that
you're one of those you know dollars
that gets put into this thing and so
having that clear lever of value is a
huge huge advantage you clearly have
that you have a huge platform that you
can talk about these companies around
organically and you know help support
them along the way the key is like
there's no free lunches right and you
can't just be promoting companies
constantly on your on your different
networks and channels and so it's
finding that balance where it's like hey
people care about the things that i care
about i'm only going to invest in
companies that i'm really passionate
about that i believe strongly in and so
when i'm talking about them i'm not
shilling this company i'm talking about
something that i care about because if
i've invested in it it matters to me
and so i think drawing that line is
really important long term sick okay i
am definitely going to hit you up to
chat about this more because this sounds
actually kind of fun but what else is in
the sahel portfolio yeah all the media
stuff so podcast you know we have
sponsors on every episode that's growing
nicely and doing well newsletter you
know uh sponsored send it out twice a
week over the course of the month and
then i have like a handful of random
things like job board i have a course
that i run from time to time i've got a
couple of affiliate things for stuff
that i really am excited about and
products that i use a lot and kind of
like a smattering of other things and
then i'm a co-owner of a couple of
businesses on the side that i don't talk
about publicly that are just kind of
cash flow streams in general nice that
sounds pretty cool so you've got this
portfolio yeah yeah
yeah i've got a i mean like
when you talk about diversity of income
streams i've got a lot um which is great
i mean it's from two years ago where i
had one to today where i feel like i
have a ton that's been pretty exciting
for me to see that all play out and you
know look from my from my prior time and
experience in the in the private equity
world i still have you know kind of
profit interest in the funds and then
different companies that i invested in
from those days so i do feel pretty
diversified more more broadly across
across a bunch of different things that
i get energy from which is great what
does your daily calendar look like very
open man i love it i intentionally don't
spend yeah i mean i don't spend time on
calls really anymore and this has been a
big shift for me i used to be i mean in
finance it was like you were called to
call just stacked over and over over the
course of the day and i've just got i
got so burned out from that so now i
mean i almost don't take calls like
other than for the fund which i will do
calls for to like deals i get really
excited about i'll do the work
beforehand to make sure i'm excited and
then i'll take a call other than that i
don't do many calls and so my calendar
is like i don't have a single thing on
it before 11am that's like my you know
morning so when i wake up in the morning
i do you know my general morning routine
is like i do some morning mobility work
for a few minutes a little bit of
breathing go get a coffee i have a cold
plunge that i just got so i'm gonna
start doing that for five minutes and
then i will sit and kind of like write
read etc generally speaking i'll have my
son with me now during that time like
he'll you know kind of sit sleep relax
with me while i do that my wife can you
know rest and sleep and then you know go
for a walk have breakfast with my wife
kind of have like a period of relaxation
i'll work out during that time and then
my day starts and my day is like blocked
into kind of blocks of focus work like i
said earlier so i'll have you know
generally speaking like 60 minute blocks
of kind of focus on something and maybe
that's recording a podcast maybe that's
doing something like this maybe it's
writing for my newsletter but just sort
of like targeted things that i'm trying
to get done maybe it's something with
the business and between those you know
i take like 15 30 minutes go for a walk
clear my head whatever it might be but
in general i'm like huge on the
unstructured schedule if you look at my
schedule on any given week it's like
massive blocks of open time what does
your team look like if if any
so i have a few different things so on
the on the agency side i have a couple
writers who help with things on that
just like you know kind of creating
content and executing on the fund it's
just me today
on newsletter i have a team that kind of
helps with the like business side of it
you know sponsors and kind of similarly
on the podcast have a team that helps
with production and sponsors and all of
those business sides of it and then i'm
kind of in the process of bringing on
like a chief of staff to just help more
broadly over the top on on kind of
everything so team is pretty light it's
you know intentionally pretty
streamlined and all of the content is
still created by me which has always
been important to me like i still write
all of my own content and uh and put all
of that out and so is this like
employees or contractors like what's
that what's the setup here contractors
contractors yeah i don't have trying to
think no i don't have any employees
formally so no no like benefits or
pension or anything like that it's all
all uh you know kind of monthly
contractors okay that's that's pretty
interesting so many more questions about
this that i'd love to ask in a in a part
two i wanted to ask before we we close
things off you're pretty ripped what's
what's your workout routine how do i how
do i get ripped like you
oh man uh 15 years of consistent
workouts no no
no i uh i'm pretty like ocd man when i
when i want to get locked in on
something i just i stick to it and so i
mean like i go back and forth i like i'm
sort of like tim ferriss and that i like
experimenting with different things and
seeing what works for me and what
doesn't so i um i have a trainer who
kind of sends me all my workout programs
i have a gym at my house um that's
that's all built out now with all the
fun stuff in it and from a diet
perspective
i you know sort of like i'll try
different things so for a month i'll do
like hardcore keto you know won't eat a
carb for a month and see how my body
responds to it i'll like do blood
testing around it and see you know how i
perform sort of a nerd about those
things right now i'm doing more of like
counting macros and kind of like doing a
carb cycling thing to see how i perform
around that but i don't know man i mean
i do i physically train every single day
i do something mainly just because i
love it like i just it's my probably my
number one hobby it's just like i love
being active i love getting outside i
love doing this stuff okay i've uh i've
got a personal trainer now you know he
comes to my place three times a week and
it's like
you know
whenever when i see it scheduled on the
calendar i'm like
i know this is gonna be hard work i know
it's not gonna be particularly fun
sometimes it is but like yesterday was
leg day and god i hate leg day and it's
like i i have some friends who seem to
genuinely love weight training
but unless i'm doing like a bench press
or just like a deadlift it does like the
two things that i enjoy everything else
feels like a lot of work and a lot of
pain a lot of suffering is there like a
mental model shift that i can make to
start enjoying this kind of stuff like
or is it like you have to do it for ages
on hot mood before it becomes easy mode
like how did
no i mean i think there's a component of
that i also think you should have it
tailored to the things you do enjoy
doing and make those like up front so
that you can find the motivation like i
will tell my trainer sometimes my
trainer will program like you know five
sets of ten rep squats and that like to
me when i look at that on my calendar
i'm just like i don't want to do this
workout because that that to me is like
sucking wind i'm going to be dying for
five sets of squats i'm not going to
feel like i got stronger because i'm
just going to be miserable and it
demotivates me and so like i'll tell him
i don't want that at the beginning like
just give me something that feels
exciting for me to dive into it because
i find that it's like it's like jumping
into a cold lake or getting into a cold
plunge
once you're in it's fine it's the like
getting in that's the hardest part and
like the anticipation of it and so i
would just like if you love deadlifts
and you love bench like have your
trainer bring that to the front like do
i mean you could do a dumbbell bench and
then a and then a bar bench on multiple
days and be totally fine or you could do
neutral grip or close grip or whatever
and like change it up but just something
that gets you into it similarly with
dead lefty trap bar you do straight bar
sumo whatever just like a hip hinge
movement that you might like similarly
like an rdl you know you can find a way
to like hack your your kind of
motivation around it sick
right style i think we'll we'll draw
this too close there thank you so much
this has been wonderful i still have a
long list of other things to ask you in
my little notebook but um hopefully we
can do a part two in person potentially
i would love to do it excellent yeah i'm
in the process of applying for an o1
visa for the us so fingers crossed that
works but if not then you're coming to
london at some point soon so we can we
can get together and record in person
sometime either way we'll make it happen
i'm looking forward to it man thank you
so much thank you so much uh where can
people find you if they want to learn
more about you i am sahilbloom on
twitter
and then my newsletter you can find at
sawhillbloom.com perfect so thank you so
much this has been wonderful take care
of yourself and uh thank you for
listening everyone see you later all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome so yeah
thank you very much for listening i'll
catch you hopefully in the next episode